في الاثناء بحث الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش مع وزير الدوله
في الخارجيه الاثيوبيه السفير مسجانو ارجا
في اديس ابابا تطورات الازمه في السودان
وقد اعرب الامين العام للامم المتحده عن
قلقه من تداعيات الاوضاع في السودان على
المنطقه وخاصه دول الجوار لكونها دولا هشه
واكد غوتيريش ان السلامه والاستقرار ينعكس
على المنطقه باكملها
ينضم الينا من ادس ابا مدير مكتب الجزيره
محمد طه توكل ما ابرز ما جاء في هذه
الزياره محمد
نعم هذه الزياره اهميتها تعكس قلق الامين
العام للامم المتحده
والامم المتحده كانت معنيه بملف مسار
السياسي للسودان وفي النهايه الطرفين
احتقموا على حوار البندقيه فبالتالي هناك
الى حد ما الاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه
الايجارات التي تقلص دورها في الشان
السوداني
واصبحت تدخلات خارجيه اخرى
استولت اليها فبالتالي ان الامم المتحده
اتت الى اديس ابواب للبحث خارطه طريق
جديده مع الاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه
الايجارات وايضا الاتحاد الافريقي بدوره
ايضا رحب على الاقل قال انه يتابع ما تجري
من المفاوضات في جده وخاصه هذه المفاوضات
حتى الان حسب تصريحات الطرفين
قالوا انهم فقط
لعمليه تمديد الهدن الجاريه في السودان
فبالتالي
نتوقع من خلال اللقاء موسع غدا بين الامير
العام للامم المتحده والرئيس مفوضيه
المتحده الافريقي سيقدموا رؤيا مشتركه
لايجاد حلب شامل ونهائي للازمه السودانيه
وايضا حيلتقي مع ايسوبيا مع رئيس الوزراء
التي لها حدود طويل
مع السودان وطبعا يعني هناك قلق حقيقي
يتجاوز
القاره الافريقيه والمحيطه الاقليمي على
مستوى الدولي لان السودان الذي له حدود مع
سبعه دول افريقيه وسبعه دول افريقيا هذه
لها حدود مع
دول عديده افريقيه فبالتالي اصبحت حيكون
انعكاساته على اكثر من 22 دوله افريقيه في
وسط وشرق وشمال القاره الافريقيه فبالتالي
التهديد يتجاوز فدا يعني قاره افريقيا
حيهدد السلم العالم وخاصه مع تزايد
المعلومات انخراط مجموعات مسلحه من عده
الدول الافريقيه في هذه الحرب الذي يهدد
ليس فقط 14 مليون سكان الخرطوم بل اكثر من
500 مليون سكان افريقيا فبالتالي الازمه
السودانيه تهدد السلم العالمي واتى الامين
العام في البحث مخرج امن وخاصه الامم
المتحده محمد يعني لها لهم انها اوصلت ما
وصل ايدها الامم المتحده نعم تحدثت عن
رؤيه مشتركه بين الاتحاد الافريقي والامم
المتحده هل رشحت اي معلومات عن عناوين هذه
الرؤيه
حتى الان هي يعني
اللجان الفنيه التي تعد
مسوده مقترحات من الجانبين لكن هي
تتركز اولا على على وقف اطلاق النار
وارسال المساعدات وايضا ان يكون اي قرارات
التي يتم التوصل اليها تكون الزاميه
للمجتمع الدولي ككل واذا هناك قلق حقيقي
من انخراط الدول الخارجيه وبالتالي يعني
سودنه الازمه وان تكون في اطار مذله
اقليميه وابعاده التدخلات الخارجيه التي
بدات تتدح يوما بعد يوما اكثر فبالتالي في
ظل
ازمه حقيقيه واستمرار القتال وتهديد
للسينما الاقليمي فبالتالي نتوقع غدا بيان
يصدر في ختام المحادثات بين الجانبين ان
تحدد الملامح الحقيقيه او خارطه الطريق
تعزز
وقف اطلاق النار او اي هدنه يمكن تمديدها
للنقط تغلق اجواء على الاقل ما مطلوب الان
من الوسطاء الافارقه واللون المتحده ان
يفتح مطار الخرطوم حتى يتمكن الوسطاء
للوصول الى الخرطوم والتحاور مع
القيادات المؤثره التي تقود المواجهات
العسكريه في خرطوم فداء شكرا لك محمد طه
توكل مدير مكتب الجزيره من اديس ابابا